europe turned upon louis the 14th at his death they learned that things had changed in the east
but let us go back a few years voronezh on the don 700 kilometers from moscow where peter the
young tsar had just made a distinguished appearance in 1689 the tsar is 17 and he prefers foreign
countries and strangers the gay life with the scottish and swiss friends to the pomp of the
kremlin at that time russia was one of the most backward countries not one scientist thinker or
philosopher not one geometrist an illiterate church a mercenary anti-monochial governing body
an arrogant pleasure-seeking nobility an archaic army and justice was non-existent
a very poor show my axe what axe what is our dear maestro up through this time that one probably
didn't have his taxes and that one's a serf that tried to run away time to go sir yes sir yes sir
well look who's here it's my valet's fault it's all his fault sorry my lord yes a thousand parts
My lord
Well go get them
Let's go, faster
There they are
They're in excellent health
Have a good blood
Take them
I guess they deserve
What is it?
It's for me
Let me see
It's goat skins
You again, stupid
Sir, you're not gonna take that, are you, sir?
Not from a woman
Woman?
Take that
Here's something to calm you
You and you will get it, you'll see.
Wait, just you wait now.
Now then, will you let go of the whip?
I'd like to have a great time.
Just you wait and see the children again.
Oh sir, you're not gonna let me pushed around by her, are you?
No woman has the right to beat up my servant world.
Hold on, it's a revolt.
You're gonna pay for this and she will too.
Just a minute, Pierre's a free man.
If his wife here has wronged you, it's his job to correct her.
director. He'll manage quite well. Come here, woman. I wonder what we'll do to her. Let's go look. What do you see?
There's a lot of activity in the naval yards in Voronage. I think I got it right now. Oh, you two, come over here. Try to cut that, will you?
Do this. Yeah, the axe. I know that'll work. I don't understand. And yet look, it cuts. Yeah, but you have to make some teeth.
And teeth, and teeth, but it never worked. The metal will break up.
Yeah, no teeth.
Let's see, let's see.
Ah, come over here.
Let's try out a brand new idea.
Oh, wow, it's working.
It's simple.
Just then, there's an unexpected visitor.
It is the year 1695.
A Russian army has just attacked Arzog to the north of the Black Sea.
But the Turks had reinforced the fortress under attack, and the offensive failed.
The Tsar Peter is 23 years old and showing some interest in his power.
He decides to build a fleet.
Your people below shipyards, my good friends.
I beg your pardon, sir.
We are extremely honored that your majesty names to find trees.
Hey, I'm the guy who's going to take care of that.
Sir, I'd like to clear up, Greybeard.
I'd like to present my latest invention.
Look at this.
A saw with teeth.
Ingenious.
And here's my young co-inventor.
We are very pleased.
Seems to like a good joke.
Let's take this man away.
The brave young man.
Schooled in exile far from the pop of the court,
Peter develops a keen taste for the manual labor of the young peasants.
He learned how to build ships from a Dutchman,
geometry from a citizen of Hamburg,
and soldiering from a Scotsman.
Yes, sir, that's my boy.
Borscht from our kitchen, sire.
On my way, I had to box with a bear on that cost of a tooth.
Yeah, one day, I was going through the forest.
I'd come upon a huge bear.
At a step on the branch, the mail is charging.
So I die to avoid him, and the two bears knock each other out, so I go peacefully home.
Following spring, the fortress of Azov, attacked this time from the sea, was to be taken from the Turks.
This is Peter I's first great victory.
May 1697, Peter I leaves Russia for the West, where he finds their learning fascinating.
He works in a Dutch shipyard.
In England, he becomes an expert in sailing and in navigation instruments.
In Vienna, he studies the martial arts.
But he had to make a hasty return to Moscow.
"Excuse me, monsieur."
"Troutsy have again revolted!"
Peter had to settle an account with this militia, who had attempted to assassinate his family when he was 10.
Swiftly and cruelly, he rid himself of this Praetorian troop, and often with his own hands.
This set off his decision to make Russia a European state,
and turned upon the most representative elements of its deep-anchored traditions:
full-length clothing.
In 1698, he went as far as to forbid the wearing of that almost sacred attribute so dear to the hearts of his subjects: the beard.
R-O-SHA!
I protest!
Really?
By royal edict, everywhere in Russia we see the clipping of old traditions,
even to the beards, and even in Voronezh on the Don.
If you please.
Pardon.
You were ahead of me.
There.
He he he he.
Uh, not now.
If you have to.
Bye.
He he he he he.
I think we could have cut it a bit shorter.
That's it.
It'll do us all good.
We'll be all fresh for the body.
for party when you the chief do you want your robe is much much too long very well much better
like that looks weird doesn't it now at least keep smiling a better entrance into Europe Peter
the Great wanted to seize the Swedish possessions that blocked his access to the Baltic but he
didn't count on a young man who was 18, Charles XII. 1700. To answer to a coalition which was
infinitely stronger than his forces, Charles XII, the Sweden, gives the attack. Does he dream of
being the equal of Alexander the Great? First he defeats the Danes, then at Narva, 8,000 Swedish
cut up 40,000 of Peter I's men. But it is there that Charles XII makes a mistake. Instead of
proceeding directly to Moscow, he makes a detour to Poland to defeat the king, the Saxon elector,
Augustus II. He again seizes Warsaw, Krakow, and defeats the Polish Saxons. Meanwhile, Russia
reorganizes her troops soon peter the first takes back narva in defiance with the help of
the prisoners of war in 1703 on the still swedish-held marshlands he builds his european
capital petersburg from every country there came friends and workers this road is in some condition
where do you put your feet ah my beard maybe i should have cut it off after all ah well
by order of a czar nobles and artisans were to report to the city to work to the administration
take charge of the work at hand look over that way chief almost there oh wonderful city and well
it's about time we got here like this we need a boss who can run this construction site oh
Good, look here. I'm the boss, understand? All right, you can go away now.
Something must be done.
But of course.
Well, of course. Come on, put your bag in there.
What?
Where's mine, great beard?
For you, I'll go look.
What about the Swedish troops?
They get stuck in the mud on the Russian steppes,
where the immensity and the cruel winter know how to treat them,
and not as well as the troops of Peter the Great.
Soon there remain nothing of the great Swedish power.
I'm a disappointed head of this construction site!
So get to work and make it fast!
And so do you think that you're the boss around here?
Yes, I'm in charge here.
No, I'm in charge here.
Me, do you understand?
No, me, do you understand?
It's me, do you understand?
No, me, you listen now!
I've seen everything.
Soldiers, take this man away!
Get away!
Tension forward march!
Eeeh!
Yeah!
It's uh, tomorrow, there's a party and we can do the good chicane food ready to bear
ahead and us against you!
The winner gets to be bought, agreed?
Yes!
Agreed!
The following day...
It's time!
Good march!
Eh...
Give it to him!
Peter the Great would have liked his country to be civilized, like in the West.
He also would have liked to teach his people, not to spit on the ground, not to pick their nose, not to kiss on the mouth.
But it's forbidden to grow a beard.
Me? But I already paid.
Oh, if you pay the special tax, then you've the right.
Not to speak with the mouthful.
You look just awful, old fellow. What is it?
Not to drink from the bottle, and many other things as well.
That's my tooth right there.
Let me see that tooth.
This implies open your mouth. It's nothing is he a czar should do almost everything my friend. Tooth legs do it. Was defeated. There was nothing left of Christoph Adolf's legacy. Henceforth Russia would be the leading power of the Baltic. Russia profited by Sweden's defeat. Now it too became a power that Russia would have to deal with. 1701. With a great deal of expert maneuvering Frederick the first secure the sought after title of King of Prussia. And now this country sees the German possessions belonging to Sweden.
In 1913, his son Frederick William reforms the country.
He imposes drastic fiscal measures and a harsh economy.
All this was to strengthen the army, but he loved it too much to send it into battle.
You see something?
That one there?
Exactly.
Uh, something wrong, old fellow?
Tavern keeper, another beer.
Come on, drink up, and that'll take care of it.
Imagine making trouble for such a nice fellow.
Another little.
Here, this is for you.
Another one now.
You know, a bit of time, a pleasure trip maybe, and it'll be fine.
That's right, yeah.
You'll have to sign now.
Yeah, yeah, that's it.
Well, that's it.
That's that.
To the king of pressure.
And to the soldiers in the army.
What's going on here?
You should be ashamed to put him in that condition.
Oh, you mind your business.
You said it. His business is mine, and mine is his business.
Insolent, you watch out now. I will skewer you. You wait.
What I do with your paper.
Miss Vendor, Mr. Judge, we're all innocent.
Revolting against the authority of Prussia is a death penalty.
Present arms left.
Just a moment.
What are you doing with these two men?
They're to be shot, Your Majesty.
But why?
In subordination to authority with violence, Your Majesty.
Let us be left alone with them.
Draw back from the prisoners 20 paces.
No, I need men like you, and so you're pardoned.
Really? Yes. On the condition you enlist in my regiment of the guard and you'll be well paid.
But my old friend wants to enlist along with me. Your old friend? He can enlist in the Canadiels.
You see, my little tin soldier. That's what I call soldiers.
Frederick Williams, the sergeant king, loved his army too much to send it out into the battlefield.
Frederick II, his son, that young blonde, that little tin soldier, would make much better use of it.